welcome to metaphysical milkshake i'm
your host reza aslan
did it work is this 2022
what are you doing what's going on rain
this is rain from the future it's future
rain and i've got to deliver a super
important message to you oh my god oh my
god this is so cool so like wait how far
in the future are you i mean
is there like people flying around in
hoverboards and stuff
no no no no no no hoverboards listen no
i've i've got to deliver this very
specific message oh my god i know it
it's about it's about micro microwaves
right they make food cold in the future
instead of hot
that's a refrigerator oh right yes uh
but i mean they make it cold faster is
what i meant to say that's a freezer
this is not working just
lay it on me lay it on me
do not
call trump a piece of [ __ ] you will get
fired from cnn
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding here right now
that was like four years ago
i thought you were gonna give me like
stock tips you could have gone to 2012
me and told me to invest in bitcoin
sorry
speaking of the future ladies and
gentlemen our guest today may be the
perfect person to talk about the future
and the future of futurism wait what
happens to bitcoin welcome to
metaphysical milkshake the show where we
go deep we get weird and we search for
the meaning of life along the way
presented by cast media and soul pancake
[Music]
all right well you're absolutely no good
when it comes to the future
uh fortunately we do have somebody
who can actually help us navigate this
rather heady topic of
what will the future be like yes our
guest is jane mcgonagall she is called
the current public face of gamification
she's got her phd from uc berkeley
2008 she became the director of game
research and development at the
institute for the future can you believe
there's a place called the institute for
the future she's written so many uh
great books including uh reality is
broken all about gaming but her new one
is so exciting it's called imaginable
how to see the future coming and be
ready for anything please give an ice
cold milkshaking welcome to jane
mcgonigle
jane we filmed a silly little kind of
comedy sketch for ted talks way back
when like eight years ago something like
that
yes and that is literally the only
comedic scene i've ever filmed so
thank you for like helping me check off
a bucket list of doing comedy with an
all-time comedy great oh well stop you
were fantastic by the way it was
me rain wilson was dating
these ted talks and i fell in love with
her ted talk and it's very meta
but um
listen you've got a new book out
imaginable
uh we're going to talk about a lot of
stuff here today
and um it's about futurism i don't i
don't i'm sure that's not a word you
like to use but predicting the future
and
what possibilities the future hold but
here i am here we are recording this
a week into the invasion of the ukraine
since you're a futurist
jane is this the beginning of world war
three
i think it ends better than it started
although um that tends to be my default
i think
it's a wake-up call i mean if you know
i really think what it will lead to is
rapid
abandoning of fossil fuels because i
think what we're what so many nations
are realizing is they don't want to be
dependent on russia for gas anymore and
so i think in the long run it'll be good
really really good for climate action i
don't know i do i do tend to look at
even the
most difficult
realities as a as a possible password to
something better that's my annoyingly
optimistic default so i think i like
that and you know and also
here we have an excellent example uh in
under horrific circumstances of the
world kind of really coming together um
at least with its economic policies and
willing to take a hit at the gas tank
and the oil prices and in various other
economic ways to economically punish
another country the most i've ever seen
that in my adult life um
and that is
there's something positive about that
that the world can move against a tyrant
and you know we're seeing a lot of
countries be more welcoming to refugees
than they have in the past and
you know course they're white refugees
so that's b they're white refugees who
are driving their volvos to the border
refugees they're more than welcome to
come in yes and um
one of the features that i
spend a lot of time imagining is the
future of climate migration
and i do think one of the most important
challenges for the next decade or two is
for all of us to
prepare to welcome people who have to
move
because the climate where they live no
longer supports um human life and
even though
this current acceptance of refugees is
founded in
racism and feeling comfortable with
white christian
refugees
even so it may set a template or model
for being more welcoming and maybe
living through the experience of having
this welcoming and realizing that it's
not something to fear and you know for i
have seven-year-old daughters and i hope
that they will see this and see
see how heroic it is to welcome others
and and that we'll have a generation
grow up being less scared of
of migrants um i you know again it's i
never want to argue ourselves out of the
possibility of something better even if
even if we're angry and frustrated at
the
the some of the aspects of the present
reality so yeah
i think you i think you're right i i
really do think that this will open the
door
to a better attitude towards um
possibly white non-christian refugees
even
so there's that we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna move the needle further than
that
i really hope jane i'm just messing with
you but uh so you know
what i what i love about you is that
you're a lot of different things you
know you're a game designer you're a
thinker you're a writer but i guess i
guess primarily
if i were to describe you with one word
i'd call you a futurist that's kind of
what we're here to talk about is
is the future but i gotta be i gotta be
frank i'm not exactly sure
what a
futurist is or like how you get into the
to the game i imagine what you do is you
like you read the palm of the world is
that what you do
oh yeah i mean i often i describe it as
having your ear to the ground and
listening for clues yeah what is a
futurist tell us what is that i would
say that
as a futurist my job is to help people
imagine
possibilities that some people would say
are unthinkable because they don't want
to think about them like the realities
of of the climate adaptation we're gonna
have to do
um or futures that people describe as
unimaginable because they just don't
believe that that kind of positive
transformation is possible you know i so
maybe as a futurist i try to convince
people that universal basic income is
not beyond the realm
of the imaginable that we could imagine
this economic policy being adopted and
we can imagine how it would affect our
own lives or i talk about geoengineering
people can't even think about
geoengineering as a possible
solution to
to climate change because we don't maybe
know enough about it we don't understand
the technology of the science the risks
the potential harms you know if we try
to stop some of the solar
radiation in order to cool the planet
while we get off fossil fuels
that may create uneven temperature
changes flooding in some regions how can
we make it equitable and safe so i try
to help people imagine things that it's
it's pretty hard to think about because
we've never done it before we've never
lived through it before and my
particular
you know process or methodology is
through
creating games and and
playable scenarios so people can really
visit these features almost as if they
were virtual worlds where they could
look around and say okay what's
happening what's the new normal how do i
feel what are the opportunities what am
i worried about and we try to bring
together tens of thousands of people
to immerse themselves in the same
scenario at the same time so we can
we can share our points of view in the
future and also maybe get some data
about how are people likely to react or
feel and and maybe some of the
surprising social consequences so we're
not so caught off guard
by how people react to unprecedented
events you bring up an amazing example
of that early on in the book
and i love that you use these words uh
unthinkable and unimaginable and you
bring up the fact that in the last two
years
uh in the news you traced like tens of
thousands of times that those words were
used in the media like this this action
is unthinkable and what happened here is
unimaginable and so you're seeking with
your book imaginable to imagine the
unimaginable and in 2008 you did a
simulation this is absolutely
fascinating
10 000 people worldwide you asked them
how they would react during a pandemic
participants were simply to predict how
they would personally feel and how they
would do in their lives
with a rapidly spreading outbreak how
would they change their habits what kind
of social interactions would they have
what kind would they avoid would they
work from home with a government
government mandated quarantine what kind
of problems would they experience and
under what circumstances would they
resist voluntary quarantine and social
distancing etc etc and
some really amazing things happened
out the other side here you know three
four years later
after this experiment can you talk us
through it
sure yeah so
my approach to figuring out what the
future holds is to start with the
premise that we are all experts on our
own futures so we can all
intuit how we might react in a future
event even if we've never experienced it
directly before so i want to go right to
to individuals and say how would you
react what decisions would you make so
with this 2008 game superstruct
we were asking those questions and
there were patterns emerging we saw that
the number one reason people would
refuse to isolate was religious worship
that it was so deeply ingrained in their
values and their purpose they don't care
if they were contagious they didn't care
if they were you know exposed they
wanted to go um and so that that emerged
in the data then as a real super
spreading risk and
when 2020 rolled around and i was
starting to
you know realize that well the reality
we imagined is actually happening
some of the first people i reached out
to in my network of people who had
worked with me at the institute for the
future to think about the future of
worship and the future of congregation
the future of religion i said you have
to
you have to go virtual because people
are going to come to your church
services are going to come you predicted
virtual churches
oh i mean yeah we i mean our players
predicted right so um i mean that's the
great thing is i don't have to imagine
everything people imagine based on
what is most important to them we had
people imagining the future of
professional sports and how they would
have to adapt in the future of schools
we had moms saying you know this is
going to be a problem for me if school
shut down how am i supposed to work i'm
probably going to have to take care of
my kids and of course we saw how many
women dropped out of the workforce for
for child care in the real pandemic
so you know it's it's interesting
in some ways it's impossible to predict
the future but if we talk to people now
about the things we might experience
we can get really useful actionable data
and
beyond that
people who participated in the
simulation and i just want to make sure
it's clear they spent
they spent six weeks in that particular
game
showing up every day
seeing new headlines you know how is it
spreading um what are you know people
were experiencing long versions of the
illness similar to long covid so they
were talking about you know
how they were trying to think about
caretaking for family members who now
had a long-term disability and so every
day the story was sort of unfolding and
they were reacting to new information so
after six weeks of this
you know
when the real pandemic rolled around i
heard from so many players that
they felt just a little bit less shock a
little bit more recognition or
pre-recognition like they it felt like a
memory even though they hadn't really
lived it and that allowed them to
just suffer a little bit less right a
little bit less
of that anxiety and hopelessness because
they're meant so their mental health was
better by imagining
what uh what could transpire by
imagining the unimaginable
yeah and i think you know it's it's
because when we run these simulations
we're always asking people to imagine
how they would use their skills and
abilities and their own voice to try to
help others and i think this was a
really important part of the the game
methodology as we sort of evolved it
over different simulations is that when
people focus on helping others it does
take them out of that mindset of being
helpless and feeling like they have
agency we are often
we can often sort of
with less anxiety if we are focused on
helping others and so people already
pre-thought you know well what could i
do what are my strengths and and they
were ready to act and so
you know even though i'm asking people
now to imagine futures that they really
don't want to think about turning off
the sun that doesn't sound fun you know
welcoming a billion migrants i am
feeling not not excited about that some
people would say but by thinking through
it now and pre-feeling it now
i really think we're going to be
able to
face whatever reality we wake up in
with more hope and confidence that we're
ready for it
rain did you know that certain physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
even digestive issues can be indicators
of stress i did i did know that you
didn't know that yeah i mean i i get i
get like weird little
uh rashes on my fingers sometimes when
i'm stressed out and in fact those
rashes are what tell me that i'm
stressed out and also don't forget about
all the doom scrolling that we do
nowadays and the the sleeping too little
or sleeping too much the under eating
the overeating it's all it's all a bit
overwhelming sometimes i can totally
relate i definitely relate to the teeth
grinding and as someone who personally
has an anxiety disorder stress is
something i really need to monitor it's
something i need to keep an eye on and
practice self-care while undergoing so
stresses are just so common these days
they show up in all kinds of ways and in
a it's an it's a world that's telling us
reza to do more accomplish more sleep
less grind all the time
hey
we are offering you a reminder to take
care of yourself right now do less and
maybe try some
therapy well i got an idea
what about better help
i love it better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
you could just like do it in your pjs
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy give it a try and see if online
therapy can help lower your stress
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and metaphysical milkshake listeners
will get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
milkshake that's b e t t e
e
milkshake and as we always remind you
dear listeners please take care of
yourself
milkshakers you know what it turns out
that everything you think you know about
probiotics may be wrong everything
everything reza so there's good news
seed
seeds daily synbiotic is the real deal
not all probiotics are created equal so
what is the daily symbiotic
it's a broad spectrum two in one
probiotic plus prebiotic a proprietary
formulation of 24 distinct probiotic
strains in scientifically studied
dosages proprietary engineered
two-in-one capsules that protects
probiotics through digestion to ensure
delivery to
the colon you know i've taken probiotics
before and
i've noticed a little bit of difference
but this thing
these guys are right like this ad copy
this isn't nonsense man this stuff
really really works i've got great gut
health i'm eating better i'm pooping
like two three times a day it's
fantastic
and i think that's exactly what the
symbiotic does it supports benefits in
and beyond the gut
yes seed will support ease of bloating
healthy regularity ease of evacuation if
you know what i mean
but here's what i love about it is that
it also supports your gut barrier it
gives you skin health heart health and
also micronutrient synthesis
many people see improvements in their
digestion within 24 to 48 hours i
certainly did and that can include bowel
movement regularity and eased bloating
those of you who you know live with a
partner they'll thank you for the ease
to bloating if you know what i mean so
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com
milkshake and you can use the code
milkshake to redeem 20 off your first
month of seeds daily synbiotic that's
c.com
milkshake and use the code milkshake
folks you don't have to suffer anymore
another thing that you do of course is
that you um look at certain trends maybe
trends that perhaps the rest of us
aren't really noticing or maybe we're so
immersed in it that we don't really get
it and then you by studying those trends
you try to kind of collect enough data
to then come up with some kind of future
scenario is there something like going
on like right now that that the rest of
us probably aren't really paying that
much attention to but like you as a
futurist are focused on because you're
thinking to yourself well see this is a
trend that that's going to have some
major ripples
uh in in the future anything you want to
share with us and yeah should i get my
uh stock broker on the on the phone
i mean the
the pattern that i'm most fascinated by
right now are patterns around
what many people call the great
resignation so people during the
pandemic rethinking their commitment to
certain types of work
uh there's a movement in china called
the lying flat movement where young
people right are refusing to grind
for society and and for the government
and they just want to do as little as
possible
there's the nap ministry which looks at
rest as a form of resistance
particularly as a form of black activism
to
to to nap and and reclaim our right to
opt out of toxic productivity and
capitalism i mean there's these are
people without kids i just want to i
want to emphasize uh oh no
no no no
i i hear you but actually uh i believe
that the founder of nap ministry is also
a mom and people in this movement we
rest with our children they can lie in
bed with us they can they can nap with
us um but there is definitely a pattern
of of you know i call it the i prefer
not to you know um like just
we're done with this grind and this
constant hustle that's bartleby the
scrivener
it is it is oh my god i got that
reference
see how smart i am reza
i don't even know herman miller's famous
story um
bartleby the scrivener this guy shows up
to work and they're like uh can you make
these copies and he's like i'd prefer
not to and they're like can you take out
the trash like i'd prefer not to can you
do these accounts i'd prefer not to and
he just he sits there like a weird
stalker and uh anyways but radical right
it's just like radical resistance and i
do i'm looking at it i'm wondering about
the possibility of
global work strikes you know i mean what
does the next
wave of social protest and social
activism look like
i think there's something
coming you know with the movement to the
four day work week is is also kind of a
part of this and so
i'm looking for you know what are the
good possibilities out of this what is
the friction going to be um what what
might support this new world um and uh
and and so
yeah that's what i'm paying attention to
i don't know exactly where it's going to
go but i do i do think we should be
prepared for a refusal to grind and i am
here for that
person it's so interesting because i
literally yesterday jane and reza was
having this conversation with my son
and he's kind of in his angsty
rebellious teens a bit and he gets good
grades but sometimes he just lets his
grades just fall like
he'll all of a sudden be failing a class
and then have to like dig himself out of
a ditch and
i was like yeah you want to get good
grades you know why do i need to get
good grades and i was like well you need
to apply yourself and and really do the
best you can if you don't get a great
grade that's fine but do your best well
why
and and why do i need a good grade and
you know i couldn't really answer him
because in my mind i was like
does it really matter
if he goes to
like a
top
liberal arts school versus a middle
liberal arts school versus whether he
goes to santa monica community college
and delivers pizzas for a couple years
and gets some life experience and then
transfers someplace like he's not going
to law school right he's not going to
business school he's not going to go to
med school so does it really matter it's
more about the process of living and
learning but this track of you know
this and the you feel it in the schools
and the urban centers especially this
pressure for test scores and grades and
extracurriculars to get to the very best
college and i understand that
there are economic insecurities out
there but it really does it does bring
into question
this whole track that we're on well and
you know i think a lot of young people
see the world on fire and there is
unfortunately some fatalism too you know
if we're going to let the planet burn
why bother which is not how i want
people to feel i don't know if you if
either of you saw there was a landmark
study published by lancet in the journal
of public health at the end of 2021 they
surveyed over 10 000 young people ages
16 to 25 from 12 countries five
continents and
56
of these young people said that they
feel humanity is doomed and they
personally have no future and the
the top reason why was
they were confused and anxious about the
failure of government to act on climate
change
and so you know while i personally think
it would be great to
resist through rest and and opt out of
you know burnout
culture and all of that it's also at the
heart of it there's a real despair too
that
i hope
in my work to help people address to
sort of feel like we there are positive
futures still left for us i don't want
half of you know young this next
generation half of them feel like
they're doomed that we're all doomed we
shouldn't let that happen to to the next
generation
so one of the ways to address this uh
jane is in gaming you're a big gamer
you're started as a game designer
and there is a correlation here in your
book imaginable about predicting the
future how to see the future um with
gaming and futurism
you know how how to think like a gamer
and how can that help us you say to
develop an ability to notice change
before it happens then to have the
opportunity to decide what to do in
response to that change amplify it
accelerate it resist it or work to
prevent it you also talk about thinking
about life thinking about the future
like a game of chess
you know not being overwhelmed by that
infinite range of possibilities because
there's like
you know google plex
number of moves in a chess game but
playing the next best moves and playing
out various simulations in your head and
and finding a place to go so how can we
what can we learn from gamers
as we forge our future
i love that question
so
the first thing i would say is that the
best metaphor for the future when we're
using games as a metaphor is definitely
a massively multiplayer game right
because
every action any of us takes affects
what
the the realm of possibilities will be
it's not just two people sitting across
each other you know over a chess board
it's billions of people making moves
every day and so you know the first
metaphor that i
really want to shift people towards is
is really feeling like
we we are all playing this game together
and that we're all making
actions every day that determine how the
future turns out now there is something
at the neurological level that i get
very excited about in terms of gaming
and how it can change our relationship
to the future
so are you either of you familiar with
this infamous study from the 1960s on
dogs that created a theory called
learned helplessness
it's one of the most controversial
american studies um in the history of
psychology i will say my dog is pretty
helpless oh
um probably because you take such good
care of your dog doesn't need to be
helpful um so these researchers they put
some dogs through some painful electric
shocks
and for half of the dogs there was a
little like button they could press when
they were flailing around from pain and
if they hit the button the shock stopped
and the other half of the dogs there was
no button and there was nothing they
could do and they just had to endure the
shocks so that was the first day of the
experiment on the second day of the
experiment they took the same dogs and
put them in another torture device and
this one was
the shocks were coming from the floor
and they had to hop over a little
barrier to get to
the side without shocks and the dogs
that had found the little button the day
before and like okay there's something i
can do i can help myself they jumped
over this barrier and the dogs that had
previously had no way to help themselves
they didn't even try even though it was
just as easy for them to jump over the
barrier they just lay down and took the
shocks
and while we would not do this it would
not be legal or ethical to do the study
today it gave birth to this this theory
that has been one of the most
fundamental theories in psychology
learned helplessness if we experience a
situation or context in which we have no
control over the outcome then we will
just kind of lie down and take it in
other areas of our lives and it was used
to explain depression and and traumatic
responses but what is amazing is that
one of the original researchers on this
study decades later became a
neuroscientist and he went back to study
the same phenomenon and he realized that
they had it completely backwards when
you actually look at what's happening in
the brain
it actually turned out that the dogs
were not learning helplessness it turns
out that we all assume helplessness as
our default response to a new adverse
environment or situation and that the
sort of deepest hardwired instinctive
response to a threat or risk is to
freeze it's like a defensive passive
strategy and it turns out that the
reason those other dogs jumped over the
barrier is because they learned their
own power
and
to me that explained everything i'd ever
seen in gaming because gamers have so
much
agency and confidence you know in in
scientific studies if you give gamers
puzzles that literally have no solution
they will stay there and keep trying to
solve it they're just convinced there's
a way i'm gonna i'm gonna figure this
out um and
games are this
games are basically like a psychological
experiment to teach you your power right
you're in the game you're figuring out
what can i do what are my abilities what
are the power ups i can collect and
every time you play a game you're
essentially learning your power and so
that's why i think games are such a
helpful tool for thinking about
future
you know worlds we might wake up in is
we can learn our power before we get
there so that we're not shocked we're
not freezing
um which so i think many of us did in
this pandemic our sort of natural
response was like ah and we we didn't
we didn't necessarily act quickly or
adapt quickly so we can try to why is
the way is the cliche of gamers that
they're in a cloud of bong smoke in
their mom's basement with their xbox and
in their lives in you know in the in
their in their fantasy game they're
slaying dragons and they're shooting
aliens but in their lives you know
they're they're working at uh little
caesars you're describing my nephew no i
i feel we are not describing your nephew
i feel i don't know your nephew but if
your nephew is a gamer i mean this is
you know
outside of my future's work i i do spend
a lot of time trying to um
understand
what is the bridge between games and our
the rest of our lives because some
people do kind of use games as an
escapist tool and it's like a fantasy
for them but other gamers
developed a sense of identity and then
they like look around the rest of their
lives like how can i
how can i
use this creativity or this this
leadership skill that i developed or my
communication or my ability to handle
stressful situations and whatever it is
that they feel developing in the game
and you know it turns out the biggest
uh differentiator is just whether people
think that games are separate from
reality or whether they believe that
when they play a game they're doing
something real and so i try to avoid
um using language like instead of saying
you know well what do you want to do in
your real life you know i talk about
well your whole life right because games
are a part of our lives and we're still
the same person when we play and it's
still our same brain and it's still our
same emotions um so
yeah i try to i try to avoid that like
duality because i i do think most people
who play games experience
a sense of resilience and uh and and
creativity and it's better for them to
bring that to
their real lives than to think that it's
an escape from their real lives
rain
2022 man this is the year
that i turned 50 years old half a
century holy moly pretty soon i'll have
to you know get like coke bottle glasses
i might even have to join the uh aarp
you know i'm 55 and i've got my aarp
card in my wallet because as we get
older we're more concerned about
affordable health care lower
prescription costs and protecting social
security and medicare
aarp advocates for you and offers
financial and job resources fraud
protection help information on joining
local volunteer groups and so much more
because aarp knows that you have a lot
of good years ahead a lot is is pushing
it you have a few a few good years ahead
well that's what's so important about
this like you know people think aarp is
just for old people
but i you know it's time to rethink our
definition of old right i mean that's
right it could help you with financial
planning retirement social security
resources and
i know somebody who loves the aarp
magazine you know i love it it's
delivered right to my door so try the
benefits listeners yourself go to
aarp.org milkshake to join for just
twelve dollars for your first year
with automatic renewal you'll get a
second membership for free plus aarp the
magazine
and a free gift an adult diaper that was
a joke that's aarp.org
milkshake
one of the fun things about the book
imaginable is that it's full of games
like there's literally all these fun
little games that you could play to help
you you know become better at predicting
the the future and one of them is this
uh turn the world upside down
game which uh both reign and i were very
fascinated by can you describe what what
that is real quick and then maybe we'll
play it oh oh
it's amazing
so yeah this is like the simplest habit
that you can pick up from the book so
you pick a topic like the future of food
or the future of books or the future of
school and you make a list of 100 things
that are generally true about it today
like you know if you're doing school
you'd say well at some point high school
ends and you get to graduate right you
just like list some facts like school is
a place that you go
or uh in school there's generally like
20 or 30 students per teacher right so
you write down all these facts it just
describes the way the world works and
then you rewrite each fact
so that the opposite is now true so it's
like creating all of these upside down
worlds so there are there are 20 or 30
teachers per student
yes absolutely and you know in the
upside down world that you're talking
about yeah the upside down world where
high school never ends there are 30
teachers for every student and school is
it's not a place that you go anymore
which is actually you know an
upside-down world we we did many of us
live through but you do this as a way to
kind of unstick your mind about what's
possible and then the most important
part is a lot of times you'll come up
with these lists of facts that just seem
so ridiculous so absurd um you know i
was doing this with some local uh
government elected officials so mayors
city managers here in the state of
california um a couple of months ago and
so there were facts like well there's a
there's a minimum voting age you know
and so we had all there's a maximum
voting age or there's no minimum voting
age and it sounds ridiculous but what we
always do with these upside down futures
is then we start looking for clues that
these seemingly impossible changes maybe
they're already happening and it's so
easy all you have to do is go type your
upside down fact in google
and see if anything comes up so you know
you could go ahead right now and type
maximum voting age into google or babies
can vote into google and you know what
there are think tanks and policy centers
trying to lower the minimum voting age
to zero because they feel like young
people have the most on the line in in
our current elections and we shouldn't
disenfranchise people um
so it's like this it's a simple simple
easy way to expose ourselves to ideas
outside of our everyday lives and and
outside of our area of expertise and
and so yeah it's fun i do it i literally
do it every week just to kind of keep
my mind open to to ridiculous
possibilities all right well let's uh
let's do this i don't think we have time
for 100.
yeah no you can do you can do three or
four four how about four facts and how
about the topic something that rain and
i both are sort of involved uh with in
one capacity or another meme far more
than reign uh the entertainment industry
let's do that let's do entertainment
four facts
um the entertainment industry uh creates
content that are consumed by um
viewers
we experience entertainment primarily
through screens
we
go to entertainment to
escape
our everyday
lives we think of entertainment as
escapist
okay that's three that's good okay let's
reverse it um we go to entertainment not
to escape our lives but to learn more
about our lives engage more fully with
our lives oh okay you flipped jane's all
right i'll flip yours um
entertainment
uh
is
a
user
created user generated
audience generated yes or you could do
ai generated right algorithmically
there isn't an enter in other words
there's no like entertainment industry
makers generated group gen as opposed to
a handful of elites you know on a
writing staff or producers generating it
and then instead of screens jane i've
yes let me let me flip reza's because i
love i love that one so i mean i think
this is a totally reasonable prediction
in the future we experience
entertainment primarily
as a as a sound experience um
and uh
i say that only because i know
so
many game companies that are interested
in getting gamers to put the phones in
their pockets and to be
present in their everyday spaces getting
input from the game primarily through
sound i was a big fan of the of the
movie dune
and the soundtrack i realized that it
was the soundtrack that i liked more
than anything else like it was that hans
zimmer
surround sound thumping
he created alien musical instruments for
it it was really
uh it was really insane i thought you
were going to say jane instead of sound
like in the future entertainment will be
experienced through the skin
oh yeah so tactile and all that could be
through through
neurotransmitters one of the um
research areas that i've been looking at
is is neurostimulation and might we add
a component to our
our
social experiences or our entertainment
where where
our vagus nerve is activated to feel
vicariously the emotions of others
whether it's others in our social
network or characters on screen
not saying this is necessarily a future
i would want to wake up in but the
technology is uh
is definitely being developed so um you
know and it's funny one of the one of
the simulations i ran
this was in 2016 was thinking about
would we get on a social network that
was primarily
neurosensing and was trying to share our
authentic thoughts and feelings totally
unfiltered just automatically going out
there and we had 10 000 high school
students
imagine you know would you join it would
you let your parents follow you or would
you block them you know how would it
affect learning and dating and activism
and entertainment and uh you know i most
people i talk to about this technology
think it sounds a little dystopian like
a little black mirror i can't believe it
would be nobody would do that but man
the high school students were ready for
this technology so it did change my uh
it sort of made me feel like maybe this
is more plausible than i was thinking
because they really did make a
compelling case for why
after the age of you know filters and
curating our lives online we might just
say you know effort here's my whole
authentic self that would be a that
would be a plot twist so jane
throughout this book now this book uh
imaginable is so wonderful because it it
takes you the reader into this kind of
series of games of like hey let's
imagine the future together and here's
how to do it and
oh here's practice hard empathy that's
so good but you do slip a couple of
wonderful predictions of your own in
there and i love this idea of the
medicine bag can you give us a super
short synopsis of that prediction yeah
so the scenario medicine bag in this
future everybody gets their own personal
tote bag with a qr code on it and they
can take it to any
farmer's market or grocery store
and you can fill it for free with fresh
fruits and vegetables because it turns
out that
if you give people free healthy food
it has such a powerful
benefit in terms of preventative health
of preventing heart disease strokes
diabetes it is
it is vastly cheaper to
give away
bags and bags of free oranges
instead of
paying for your diabetes yeah and there
you know there are movements like there
is a food is medicine movement there are
pilot programs that are doing this you
know it sounds it sounds unimaginable
that like we're just gonna i mean right
now we have such a punishing system if
you if you're on food stamps it's so
controlling i mean
there's so much scarcity baked into our
food systems right now it sounds
ridiculous to imagine this incredible
just abundance i like to think of it as
like supermarket sweep a show i grew up
with and was glad that it was relaunched
you know like what would it feel like to
go into these environments and know that
you can have as much as you want and
it's free and that feeling of just
abundance and just
you know give it to me and one of the
things that i try to get people to do
with these scenarios is you like take
them into reality with you
and it's like your own augmented reality
device like in your brain you can next
time you're at a farmer's market you're
in the grocery store look around and
imagine that this is all free for you
and how does that change how you eat and
how you cook and how you live and when
we when we can look around the real
world and see how it could be different
i really do think that empowers us to
find out more about the people who are
trying to make things different the
movements the policymakers the activists
the
you know creatives engineers and yeah so
i do i love that one too
that's fantastic and i love especially
that it's farmers markets because then
you're increasing local farmers you're
eating locally which is such a big part
of the food movement yeah i love it sign
me up for that but
this gets to something
you this prediction gets to something
that i just love about your work is that
there's a positivity here that isn't um
hey everything is going to be great you
guys it's it's not an abject kind of
uh
oppressive positivity you know some
people are like hey just stay optimistic
and it's like no
that it doesn't work and it also doesn't
read a sci-fi too which i really
you know like sometimes you you
sometimes are these futurists you see
all the time who are like
we'll have chips and it'll take care of
all disease and i'm like okay but what
about like the next few years i mean can
we talk about that
well you know a lot of futurists are
described themselves as techno optimists
like well technology will solve
everything and i i feel like i'm more of
a socio-optimist i believe that humans
will solve everything through our
fundamental ability to
to
make change for the better and
and so i you know i do
there is that fundamental optimism but
it's it's paired with urgency you know
like the technology is not going to save
us that's what i wanted to get to
because you you have
a couple phrases in this book that
really popped out to us one was this
hard empathy and i love that idea of
like there's easy empathy like you see a
video of a kitten with a hurt toe and
then it gets nursed back to health
you're like oh that's easy empathy hard
empathy is like
oh there's a white supremacist who lost
his family in a in a fire or something
and it's really hard to relate
something that's harder to relate to to
practice that empathy but but hand in
hand with that is you we're talking
about optimism but you talk about urgent
optimism and i love this concept
you talk about it as having a
psychological flexibility a realistic
hope an agency and an efficacy to impact
how the future turns out talk to us
about the necessity of urgent optimism
yes so
you know urgent optimism it's a balanced
mindset right so it's a combination of
of positive imagination and shadow
imagination it starts with being willing
to
acknowledge
the the risks that we face the
injustices that exist
and we're not afraid to talk about it or
think about it
but it's also paired with
the ability to identify
and learn about the new
policy ideas the new technologies the
new social movements the things that
can give us hope that we can we can
prevent those risks we can we can solve
those injustices that we can resolve
conflicts through these these reasons
for hope and and you know as a futurist
it's this constant
you know yin yang it's like
we got to worry about some stuff but
like wow there's so many amazing people
with all these creative ideas and this
passion to make things better and so we
try to hold them both in balance so we
feel like
it is our responsibility to act and make
the future we don't want the future to
just happen to us we're not going to let
the future just happen to us we have to
find
the all of the levers that we can you
know press that might make things better
you're really talking about urgent
optimism as a cure for learned
helplessness aren't you
well exactly yes it's it's trying to
find our power to make a better future
and and to to help others find their
power so that we can
we can imagine a world we actually want
to wake up in and then make it right
them really make up
well jane uh you are the only guest that
we have had in our i don't know coming
up on like 60 or 70 episodes of uh the
metaphysical milkshake who is actually
looking forward to the lightning round
and i'm assuming i'm assuming that's
because you're a futurist
and and i've predicted all these
predicted that you're all yeah you're
going to do well in this uh
it's also because i've always dreamed of
being on a game show and this is this is
truly
i've never been so this is my this is my
game show interesting fact for every
question you get right you get some
groceries so this will be
experience for you okay are you ready
lightning round
what three items would you choose if you
were stranded on a deserted island
um and i assume we can't just pick my
husband and my two kids no well do you
think of them as items uh
for your disposal because if so then yes
yes actually i would not want to inflict
that suffering on them but i would bring
a device that i could play tetris on
um to to help me deal with the trauma of
the situation and i would bring
um
some uh candy sugar
candy and tetris candy and tetris are
you eleven
wait a minute here that's exactly what
my 10 year old would say
what's one tip you can give parents that
you think would help with their
children's happiness oh my gosh if your
child loves a game
ask them what does it take to be good at
this game so that you can understand
better the skills and strengths that
they're building and you can validate
that they are real and that you see them
that you see what is good in them when
they play their games and not just
whatever you you know your anxiety about
games that you actually see what's good
in your kids when they play i love that
what's something that a lot of people
like but that you can't stand
i would say most popular music i have
absolutely terrible taste in music i've
been told my whole life i mostly like
you know toto
devo and broadway musicals and other
than that i'm really not wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait no
toto has a 1982 the people who listened
to toto did not listen to devo true you
can't listen you can't listen to toto
and devo that's true that doesn't
it's a contradiction there
do you only listen to four four letter
bands it could be let me wham love wham
[Laughter]
the cure
yeah i'm good
if you could interview anyone living or
dead who would it be and what is the
first question you would ask
i would like to interview one of the
monks
at the san francisco zen center
and
i would like to
ask them
about
about hope and about optimism i mean i
would like to have a deep conversation
about
um
where optimism and buddhism intersect
that's just something the great thing is
living or dead that's an easy that's an
easy get you can just probably walk in
the zen center
with a tape recorder unless it's a
silent meditation or something silent
retreat
sometimes we ask our guests that you
know if you could
go back in time and have coffee with
like the 19 year old uh jane mcgonagall
what would you tell her but in your case
we're going to ask you
if the 69 year old jane mcgonicle
could have
a uh conversation could have coffee with
you currently
what would the 69 year old
version of jane mcgonigal tell you now
i love that you know that's actually a
therapeutic intervention that um
that for for people who've experienced
trauma
uh asking them that question and they
write from their future selves um they
will often write stories of meaning of
like sort of how they made meaning or
found purpose
in in using that trauma to to help
others or to change um themselves or
society so i'm sure i would say
something about
um
how how much suffering we all have lived
through at this time but that it led to
something better and that it created
you know billions of people who realized
that we could change so much faster than
we thought and and felt you know
felt
compelled to
make
this this trauma meaningful by using it
to make the world better i think that's
what my 60 something year old self would
tell me i hope so
what happens to us after we die
i believe that we
live on as simulations in the minds of
people who loved us
that they can that we are almost as real
as we are that that the that the
versions of ourselves you know like if i
were to try to have a conversation with
my husband in my mind
i believe that i could even though he's
not here i i know him well enough i love
him well enough that the conversation i
would have with him in my mind is almost
as real as one i would actually have so
i think we live on as simulations in the
minds of people who loved us who are
still alive that's kind of the best
answer we've ever had oh yeah and then
last but not least
what is your life's big question
how can we make this more fun
that way i would say that is my question
how can we make this more fun even the
things that are hard
how can we make it more fun are you
talking about our podcast
hey you guys made it fun today we made
it we play we play games
that's a great answer jane mcgonigle
thank you so much thank you for coming
super fun
milkshake this was absolutely a
delightful conversation uplifting
exciting folks please check out her book
imaginable i was gonna say unimaginable
it's unimaginable that you would not
pick up a copy of imaginable by jane
mcgonicle thank you so much jane
you know for somebody who studies the
future for a living she's pretty
optimistic
i
i can't i can't believe that you're
absolutely right you mentioned earlier
like the pessimism of so many futurists
ai will destroy us
they will have retina scans and recreate
you know we will neglect
jars
she really believes in the
the power and the creativity and
vitality of the human spirit to make
positive change it's it's honestly i
think i think a lot of it has like that
game the uh the upside down game
it it's sort of hard not to be
optimistic when you play it let's play
it uh let's play another version let's
play another version all right what
about what podcasts podcasts oh the
future of podcasts okay well okay one
fact each one fact each i'll start okay
okay current current true fact
about podcast um
everyone
and their mother
has a podcast
or is about to have one
okay that's my face not exactly factual
but all right i see what you mean uh
podcasts are an auditory experience oh
yours is so much smarter and more
interesting mine okay um i will i will
flip yours around
well but i see it'd be too easy to say
that it's it's going to be a video
experience because it's already a video
experience so i'm going to say
that
podcasts
will be
a primarily
uh a um
olfactory experience
a smell cast it'll just be smell casts
wait wait i'm tming this right now no
listeners do not
do not buy smellcast.com it's mine
already that's fantastic you could have
a a smell cast of of a 12 course dinner
to turn yours around everyone and their
grandmother has a podcast i will say
that you know what about a 3d virtual
podcasts where you're sitting with the
podcast hosts
and having conversations with them isn't
wouldn't it be like a more interactive
podcast
um that's true
could ai create a version of you and me
put us in a virtual room and then our
milkshakers could come in and have a
conversation with us about whatever
life's big question we wanted and the ai
having kind of downloaded our hundreds
of hours of talking would know what we
were going to say and how we were going
to say it so you have the experience of
like being in the room with rain and
reza
milkshakers you know how this goes when
you rate and review us on apple podcast
you get to come on our show and ask us
your life's big question and we have a
listener here today jared from georgia
well thank you for having me so
jared what do you got for us you've got
a life's big question that's that's
percolating away inside
so uh with all the news about the
metaverse and you know i'm not
incredibly well versed with it but it is
interesting to me
at what point does like a virtual
currency and a virtual sort of world
rival that of our reality
um just because that seems to be
the main talking point of
of the ads and of of
the meta or
facebook
and i'm just wondering uh what you think
about that boy did you come to the right
people because reign is all about the
virtual currency
he owns numerous
cryptocurrencies i didn't i did make
some early investments in the crypto
that has have turned out pretty well for
me
um sorry not to brag but uh
i was just uh dabbling but yeah i mean
you know that's such an interesting
question where are we headed um i don't
know if you ever read that book ready
player one the movie was terrible but
the book was really
cool and the fact that people live more
and more in an alternative meta universe
than they do in the actual universe but
it's interesting because well what did
we used to do like you had a lamb and
you would trade it for you know 27 years
of corn
and that was our first currency
and then
we would say well this
solid gold doubloon here with a crown
stamped on it is worth
37 lambs
so and and we'll see that currency
fluctuates up and down oh now it's worth
17 lambs now it's worth 43 lambs
um
and so
so that was happening and then you know
with the collapse with the abandoning as
it were of the gold standard
money simply becomes a number that is
tied to a central banking system uh but
does it have any actual real value if
you have a five dollar bill or a hundred
dollar bill is aren't you kind of in the
metaverse is there's a there's an agreed
upon
value to a piece of paper or to a
digital number that's in your bank
account
and now with crypto we're you simply
abandoned that currency being tethered
to a national bank
and it's just kind of mutually agreed
upon hey
let's all together just agree that one
bitcoin is worth
41 000 these days or whatever the value
is and then tomorrow it's worth 41. and
who who knows um
it can't really be propped up it can't
really be supported and
as we grow into the metaverse and then
there's going to be
its own currency it's going to have
metacurrency and there's already kind of
all this kind of dogecoin and you know
currencies that were started as a uh
as a joke
and
so it just
it it the word meta it just go it gets
more meta and more meta and more meta as
we go where does it stop
i have no idea um i don't know that it
stops until we go back to trading lambs
for corn
we might we might be getting closer to
that than you think
first of all people don't read ready
player one
if you really want a book about this
read snow crash neil stephenson's book
which invented the term metaverse
it's an amazing amazing uh book uh and
number two
look i i'm not a i'm not a
financial guy i don't really understand
economics or business or any of this
stuff so i can't really say too much
about
you know the
what what the currency stuff is except
for what what uh my co-host rain i think
eloquently said which is that all money
is fake all money is fake anyway so
people are like well virtual currency is
is so much more fake than
real currency really is that
really because it's all [ __ ] it's
all just an agreed-upon symbol so who
cares whether it's like a piece of paper
or virtual it's all the same
what i think is much more interesting
though
is
the way it's going to change the
concepts of real
and virtual like your question was like
well virtual coins
you know how will that affect you know
the the real world and
yeah the metaverse is a joke right now i
mean it's like you know early early
atari basically
um
but in 20 years from now
you know
i think a much more interesting question
will be
what is real
what is real when the metaverse looks
exactly like our world
right when we're not just like legless
cartoon figures
but actual versions of ourselves
when we're not locked to a
you know an ipad or a laptop sitting at
our desk but can actually wear the
metaverse with us everywhere that we go
then i think that we're going to have a
much more fun conversation not about
like
what's the difference between real
currency and virtual currency but what's
the difference between real and virtual
what is the difference between the two i
was reading a scientist and they were
talking about how
you know we uh make technological bio
hacks like for instance hearing aids
cochlear implants eye glasses contact
lenses these are things that what do
they enhance our physical experience in
the world right well that this this this
person was saying that our phone
uh is an extension of our mind so my
calendar is on my phone i can't remember
when i'm doing anything but it's on my
phone hasn't my phone become an
extension of who i am in a way and then
the metaverse becomes an even deeper
extension of who we are what
like reza says what is real what is not
what do you think jared what are you
what are you pondering
it is it is interesting this real
question what the nature of reality is
it's just because people
wonder all the time you know whether the
life we live in now might be simulated
just because of the you know the way
that the human body is put together
uh
the way nerves are created
it seems like the more we understand
that
the more curiosity would sort of
travel over to those areas where we want
to recreate that for some odd reason we
love to just keep recreating us you know
and and to question what is us what what
is human what is our experience and how
how do we sort of study and replicate
that and
as our technology progresses it yeah it
will get harder and harder to sort of
say hey this you should really just live
in the real world it's like well if
my nerves and my mind is just stimulated
exactly the same way and if somehow
you know they're able to feed me while
i'm in the metaverse you know then then
the ball game sort of changes you know
um and i'm just wondering like will i be
after my shift
in the real world while i work for
another four hours up you know
in a shop in the metaverse or
right or will that be automated who
knows or you know like well about do it
for me you know those are the
interesting questions i think
it reminds me that episode of the office
where dwight was in second life
um
and uh
are we all going to be living in this
second life is the second life going to
be more real than our real life i don't
know i bet you anything we've got some
listeners who can answer this question
for us find us on social at reza aslan
rayne wilson and on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram
follow us at
metaphysicalmilkshake and write us there
that's a good place to reach us at
metaphysical milkshake on instagram let
us know what you think about what's real
what's not about the metaverse
we'd love to hear all about your life's
big questions and we really
just might put them on a future episode
jared thank you so much this has gotten
my mind spinning
bless you
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man our producer safa just told me
somebody already beat us to smell cast
damn it
oh no there's a smell cast oh geez damn
it
all right it's all happening
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you